it was look guys my name is the china
rose and back to my sip of blood series
today we're going to continue on our
whole object-oriented programming
classes or that doesn't want to talk
about constructors in C++
so what is a constructor a constructor
is basically a special type of method
which runs every time we instantiate an
object so I think the best described
with an example suppose that we want to
create an empty class let's actually
dive into some code daybook we want to
create an entity class here which has
two members perhaps it has a flirt X and
a flirt Y which is basically just
describing the position of the entity if
I try and create this entity and then
perhaps maybe give it a print function
so that it can output what it is into
the console I'll just print X and have a
nice little separator comma between the
two then why I'm instantiating the
entity here and then I'm going to call
the print function if I find on this
code you can see that it will work
however I get seemingly random values
for the position of this entity and that
is because when we instantiated this
empty and allocated memory for it we
didn't actually initialize that memory
meaning that we got whatever was left
over in that in that memory space what
we probably want to do is actually
initialize the memory and set it to zero
or something like that so that our
position is zero by default we don't
specify it or set a position in the
future I'm going to make an in-depth
video about initialization for classes
and all of that so I'm going to keep it
brief here but another great example is
if we decide to manually print x and y
they're public so we can go ahead and
try and write code which prints out X
for example P dot X if we try and
compile this code you can see that we
get an uninitialized local variable e
used error message so in other words it
will not even compile because we're
trying to use memory that has not been
initialized this print function does
compile however it doesn't work the way
that we expect it to of course because
it's printing x and y however they are
set to seemingly random values so we've
already got a need for some kind of
initialization we need a way to every
time we construct an entity we want to
be able to set x and y to zero unless
we've specified some
you so what you might want to do to do
that is create an init method so I'll
create a method called internet it'll
just be void and it will just take the
job of setting ax and y to zero now what
I can do is when my entity gets
constructed I can call a dot in it and
then if I try and print my event my
values you can see that I get zero and
then when I call print I get zero comma
zero printing meaning that x and y I set
to zero wonderful however this is quite
a bit of code that we've written extra
we've had to define this in this method
and every time we want to create an
entity in our code it means that we have
to actually run that init function that
is quite a lot of extra code and
definitely not clean so whether it was a
way for us to run this initialization
code one we construct an empty in comes
the constructor so the constructor is a
special type of method which is
basically this if the message that gets
called every time you construct an
object to define it we define it like
any other method however it does not
have a return type and its name must
match the name of the class if I want to
construct it for entity I just type in
the name of the class which is entity I
can optionally give it parameters which
we'll talk about in a second or at live
blog and then I can just give it a body
and in this case I can set X to be 0 and
Y should be 0 as well we can get rid of
this igneous method and if we scroll
down here we don't need to call in it
anymore at all if I run my code now you
can see that we get an identical result
to what we had when we ran the init
method however now we'll need the init
method it's handled for us by the
constructor if you don't specify
constructor you still have a constructor
it's just something called a default
constructor it's actually provided for
you by default however that constructor
doesn't actually do anything it's
basically equivalent to this it does
nothing so those things that is
initializes your variable at all in
languages such as Java primitive types
like int or floats are automatically
initialized and set to 0 that is not the
case in simple slots you have to
manually initialize all of your
primitive types
otherwise they will be set to whatever
was left over in that memory so very
very important that you don't forget
about analyzation again I'm going to
talk more about initialization in a
future video and
strategies and ways to initialize memory
correctly so definitely check that out
when ever I get around to making that
let's take a look at a constructor with
parameters so I can write as many
constructors as I want of course
provided they have different parameters
are the same as if I was writing methods
with the same name
however providing different overloads
for them so basically different versions
of the same method with different
parameters I'm going to add X and y as a
parameter here and I'm going to assign X
and y to x and y so basically I'm
assigning my parameter to my member
variable here I now have the option of
constructing entity with parameters so I
simply write whatever my I want my
values to be such as 10 and 5 I'll get
rid of this extra print and if I run
this I should have called get 10 and 5
printing to the console like so all
right cool that's constructors pretty
much covered constructors of course will
not run if you do not instantiate an
object so if you just use static methods
from a class it would run we haven't
talked about heap allocation yet we
definitely will in a future video
probably really really soon but of
course when you use the new keyword and
create an object instance it will also
call the constructor there are ways to
remove a constructor as well if for
example you had a log class which you
only had static methods in so for
example I had my static void log here
let's call it something like right
instead of monkey silly and I only
wanted to allow people to use my class
like Thoreau I did not want people
creating instances there's two different
strategies for sorting that out we can
either hide the constructor by making it
private like so as you can see that I
get an error here because I cannot
access the constructor if I don't do
something like that you can see it
obviously allows the construction of
this object because they both lost
applied the default constructor for us
however we can tell the compiler no I
don't want that default constructor and
we can do so by simply writing log which
is a default constructor equals delete
and if you look over here we cannot call
love like this because the default
constructor doesn't actually exist it's
delete it there are also special types
of constructor such as the copy
constructor and the move constructor
they're going to be set
videos on each of those because they're
rather complicated but to the basic use
that is what a constructor is a special
method which one whenever you create an
instance of a class the primary use for
this is to initialize that class make
sure that you neutralize all of your
memory and do any kind of setups that
you need to do whenever you creating
your object instance process we've got
so much stuff to cover I'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]